good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday
you thought you had a great weekend did
you see what barack obama did it was
way more fun than anything that happened
at your house on saturday night
for his 60th birthday barack obama threw
himself a party at his estate on
martha's vineyard right a car
right off the coast of massachusetts now
obama's place is on the ocean
naturally but unlike your oceanfront
property and say
destin obama's property has been
declared eternally exempt from the
devastating rise in sea levels that will
inevitably accompany the existential
crisis of climate change which by the
way you
caused so no matter what happens to the
global climate
obama will be safe on martha's vineyard
even if you continue to eat steak and
use air conditioning both of which will
soon be banned
ever sensitive to the feelings of his
subjects obama did his best to downplay
the size and the opulence of saturday's
event
his pr team did not mention the hundreds
of servants who would be there
the party they assured us would be
nothing at all like something king
farook might have hosted in his later
years no resemblance
barack obama's party was merely an
intimate gathering of quote
family and friends and in the end that's
exactly what it was the thing is as you
can see from the photographs
barack obama has an awful lot of very
close friends
what's interesting is who they are and
who they're not joe biden was not at the
party and that's weird considering that
joe biden and barack obama are like
brothers
as close as two straight men can be as
joe biden has told us himself many times
though if you've been watching carefully
through the years you may have noticed
that barack obama has never made that
claim he's never said a lot about liking
joe biden
now we know he doesn't so who does
barack obama like
well in a word celebrities obama likes
celebrities
lots and lots of celebrities it was like
the red carpet scene outside a lesser
award show on saturday night
there was oprah and jay-z gail king tom
hanks george clooney as well as a whole
bunch of other people who you wouldn't
recognize if you're over 30 and don't
live on social media there are a ton of
them
and it was kind of a surprise to see it
because barack obama is a genius
we know that we can be certain of it
because we have heard that claimed as
fact for almost 15 years now
and yet we now know that when barack
obama relaxes
at his own house it's not with
intellectuals or even with people who
can read books
it's with the kids he watches on tick
tock obama passes around some high fives
throws on a pair of beige slip-on shoes
and the world's only gray hawaiian shirt
and hits the dance floor it's party time
but wait a second you ask a gray
hawaiian
shirt is that even legal when you're
barack obama it is the normal rules
don't apply to you
remember that this is the man whose
staff referred to him as black jesus
totally without sarcasm so when you're
parting the waters and healing the sick
you don't get too hung up on the usual
fashion regulations
or for that matter on public health
regulations there's a global pandemic
out there you may have heard about it
and it's getting worse the cdc tells us
that the so-called delta variant is so
dangerous that we can no longer have
civil liberties in america
private property rights have been
suspended happened last week
our children must wear masks at school
again
we should not be allowed to go to dinner
fly on airplanes
have a job without first displaying our
new vaccine passports
and barack obama supports all of that
he's for all the restrictions
but that does not mean he wants to live
under those restrictions
so on saturday obama's guests did not
have to show their papers to get into
the party
unlike cnn employees they didn't have to
prove they were vaccinated
unlike your kids they didn't have to
wear masks it was like 2019 at barack
obama's house like the whole pandemic
thing never happened
the question is does tony fauci know
this and if so is he okay with it
that's a pressing public health question
so today we called tony fauci to find
out
unfortunately he was not free to do the
show he was too busy he's a scientist
he's not into publicity
he was tied up doing another photo shoot
for teen vogue so he can't come
our loss so to determine what the new
rules are we're just going to have to go
with tony fauci's previous statements
and here's what we learned when large
groups of massless people without
vaccine passports
gather in one place it is a grave danger
to america
but only when those people write
harley-davidson's
on sunday fauci once again scolded
bikers who were gathering for their
annual events in sturgis south dakota
now these people are dangerous tony
fauci told us some of them went to
community
college literally and there are some who
didn't go at all
you should be worried it's pretty much
exactly what he told us last year about
this george's rally that many would die
so we checked because numbers are
important on a news show did that happen
whatever happened to last year's sturgis
well it turned out
almost half a million people went about
450 000.
in the end fewer than 0.1 percent of
them got
covid so no millions did not die
actually it was fine but tony fauci did
not change his guidance he's not
deterred by his own bigotry and stupid
predictions you may have noticed
so here he was the other day warning us
once again about the perils of sturgis
well i'm very concerned chuck that we're
going to see another surge
related to that rally i mean to me it
it's
it's it's understandable that people
want to do the kinds of things they want
to do they want their freedom to do that
but there comes a time when you're
dealing with a public health crisis
that could involve you your family and
everyone else
that something supersedes that need to
do exactly what you want to
do well i'm very concerned chuck
bohekker so as tony fatches explained
given how dangerous to public health
those bikers at sturgis are
you've got to wonder what the risk the
rest of us face might be from barack
obama's martha's vineyard birthday party
here you have
hundreds of people indoors without masks
who haven't proven their vaccination
status
and if the numbers tell us anything
quite a few of them were not vaccinated
is that acceptable or not sincerely
that's an urgent public health question
the kind you'd think tony fauci
exists to answer as the highest paid
public sector employee
but he didn't answer the question and as
we told you we tried and he won't answer
it
so as an epidemiological matter where do
you think barack obama got the idea that
it's a good idea to hold
huge indoor events with people who
haven't proven they've gotten the shot
and aren't wearing masks
how could he have determined that well
maybe he watched his friend
muriel bowser who's the mayor of dc she
just did the very same thing
bowser you recalled forced a new mask
mandate on her city but she
delayed it within hours just long enough
to hold a birthday party for herself
and that's fine it's cool it's not like
she rides a harley
she's a democratic office holder now
if you still believe in science and are
becoming slightly confused by this
public health guidance
you didn't watch cnn this weekend
because they laid it out in the clearest
possible terms
listen to this reporter from the new
york times explain why barack obama and
his friends from tick tock
can have masculist parties indoors
without vaccine passports
at the very same moment you were not
allowed to visit
your dying parents in the hospital it's
not arbitrary it's not capricious
there's a reason a medical reason watch
other people said you know this is
really being overblown
they're following all the safety
precautions people are going to sporting
events that are bigger than this
this is going to be safe this is a
sophisticated vaccinated crowd
okay now we're talking science
so when it happens at barack obama's 12
by the way that was the purchase price
we're talking over 20 million dollar
house
on the ocean that's immune from climate
change when it happens there
it's not a problem because the crowd and
we're quoting the new york times as we
say this is quote
sophisticated and vaccinated
now we don't know about the vaccine
because they didn't have to prove it and
again
if the numbers are right a lot of them
weren't vaccinated
maybe more than half but that's not what
she was saying
the emphasis here the medically
significant word
is sophisticated right now the biden
administration is forcing
unvaccinated people to obey every
requirement that vaccinated people have
to follow
it's the sophisticated crowds that are
exempt from the rules vaccines have
nothing to do with it the question is
one of sophistication
you should also know that's the
sophisticated in this country
the king farouks who walk among us
towering above the rest
are also exempt from having to pay their
taxes
exempt from having their police defunded
exempt from having say catholic
charities move penniless immigrants into
their neighborhoods in the new section 8
housing they're building on your street
they don't have to deal with any of that
because they're sophisticated it's nice
to be just
sophisticated you know what though it's
definitely bad to be unsophisticated
because if you're unsophisticated cnn
will not come to your defense
its anchors will not defend you and you
ignore the rules instead when you're
unsophisticated they will devote
hours of coverage to mocking and
deriding you
as they did you think this is going to
be a super spreader event yeah i'm very
concerned
the slogan this year for sturgis is
we're spreading our wings but i'm
concerned they're going to be spreading
a lot more than just their wings
few attendees wore masks last year and
that's likely to be the case again
this year well this year sturgis rally
attendees are proving they didn't learn
anything from last year
drawing an even bigger crowd amid a
major surge in cases
caused by the delta variant and the
unvaccinated
the annual event kicked off over the
weekend with packed bars rock concerts
and barely any masks you think they'd
learn
but nope you'd think they'd learn
can you imagine riding a motorcycle
outside with no mask on reckless freaks
killing the rest of us you'd think
they'd learn but nope
that's the judgment of dr don lamont but
again since is
in the end this is a news program we
should remind you that there was
actually no covet outbreak
at sturgis last year but somehow no one
has told cable news
they're completely convinced it was a
super shredder event
go to cnn's website right now and you
will find a very lengthy piece with this
headline and we're quoting
south dakota's sturgis motorcycle rally
a cautionary tale in the age of kovid19
a cautionary tale cautioning against
what believing the dummies at cnn
in the piece cnn reports with horror
that there are virtually no
tick tock stars this year at sturgis
they're all martha's vineyard
oprah's never even been to sturgis
instead according to cnn sturgis
involves and we're quoting now
drag races rock concerts pub crawls
tattoo contests and processions of
harley-davidson's
through the black hills mountain range
whoa whoa you know what that means right
public health disaster or again in the
words of cnn
the sturgis rally had many
characteristics of a super spreading
event
large crowds high intensity of contact
between
people potential for highly infectious
individuals traveling from hot spots
and events in poorly ventilated indoor
environments
not at all like what they're doing under
the tent in martha's vineyard with the
tick-tock kids
it turns out they're not sophisticated
they're super spreaders and in this
country really
you're one or the other that's your
choice
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else